surrounding the headquarters of
georgia's largest opposition party
police carried out a special operation
to breach the building
opposition supporters resisted but
officers soon overwhelmed
them taking nick amelia the leader of
the united national movement
into custody
last week george's prime minister
resigned citing concerns about clamping
down on the opposition
his successor appointed on monday was
quick to take a hard-line position
i sincerely thank the entire police
force for protecting
the dignity of our state the stability
of our state
and once again reminding everyone that
we are a state governed by the rule of
law
media is accused of leading
anti-government protests
that turned violent in the summer of
2019
but the opposition says his arrest is
politically motivated
an attack on a democracy with western
aspirations
using tactics borrowed from the kremlin
believe that with detention or political
leaders they can resolve it but they all
this will only deepen the crisis
and it will only escalate the situation
therefore the only solution is that the
international community will create a
pressure on the jordan dream
and they will come back to negotiating
negotiations
and we will negotiate political
settlement which will include the early
elections
georgia has special status as an eastern
partner of the european union
and its western allies are alarmed we
are urging
all sides in georgia to show the
necessary restraint
utmost restraint and responsibility to
avoid more escalation
in the interest of the country and its
people the arrest
of the senior opposition figure
nickimelia
has deepened georgia's political crisis
which has been going on
for months now the opposition refusing
to recognize the results of october's
elections
and enter parliament behind me
efforts by western diplomats to get
georgia's political factions to talk to
one another
rather than at one another appear to
have failed
instead more protests and more arrests
may lie ahead robin forrester walker
al jazeera to belize